la réaction ferme de l'exécutif après le
meurtre d'un policier hier soir à
avignon le centre ville était bouclée
une partie de la nuit
des centaines de policiers ont été
déployés dans la cité des papes
les faits se sont déroulés plus tôt dans
la soirée vers 18h30 les forces de
l'ordre intervenaient sur un
attroupement autour d'un points de deal
un individu a fait feu sur un policier
avant de s'enfuir
la victime un homme de 36 ans père de
deux enfants est décédée sur place je ne
peux que leur précisera les conditions
de la mort de ce policier
nous pouvons déjà dire qu'elles sont
abjects qu'elle nous révulse et que ce
soir nous nous pleurons ce policier mais
mais que sa mort n'est pas vaine et tous
continueront ce combat acharné contre la
drogue et le trafic de drogue c'est le
cheval de bataille de l'exécutif ces
derniers jours le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron l'a réaffirmé dans un
entretien accordé au figaro le 18 avril
dernier
hier soir en rendant hommage au policier
tué le ministre de l'intérieur n'a pas
manqué de répéter les éléments de
langage du gouvernement la lutte contre
les trafics de stupéfiants
partout sur le territoire national
s'apparente à une guerre c'est à dire de
la meuh non grâce à des soldats ces
soldats sont les policiers les gendarmes
de france aujourd'hui un de ses soldats
est mort en héros pour lutter contre ce
trafic du trafic de stupéfiants ce
meurtre survient une dizaine de jours
après l'assassinât par un jihadiste
d'une fonctionnaire de police dans un
commissariat à rambouillet dans les
yvelines
à un an de l'élection présidentielle de
la sécurité s'est déjà imposé comme un
thème de campagne